from Sky News check this out Biden faces
pivotal moment as he weighs retaliation
for Soldier deaths in Jordan Dron strike
the commander-in-chief will have given a
number of options by the Pentagon but
the consequences are far from certain
and could trigger a wider War sky news
says as early as tonight President Joe
Biden will authorize US military action
in the Middle East it is likely to be
one of the most consequential decisions
of his presidency at stake The
credibility of American deterrence and
the teetering stability of the region
this comes after three US troops were
killed in a drone attack and 34 were
injured CNN reports that well we'll read
three US Army soldiers were killed and
more than 30 service members were
injured in a drone attack overnight on a
small us Outpost in Jordan us officials
told CNN marking the first time the US
that US troops have been killed by enemy
fire in the Middle East since the
beginning of the Gaza War we shall
respond President Joe Biden said while
speaking in South Carolina on Sunday the
killing of three Americans at Tower 22
in georia near the border with Syria is
a significant escalation of an already
precarious situation in the Middle East
officials said the Drone was fired by
iran-backed militants and appeared to
come from Syria it is still being
determined which militia group
specifically is responsible and of
course we're already seeing the
warmongers in Washington DC say strike
Iran now with the reporting that Joe
Biden will be authorizing some form of
retaliation tonight many are speculating
this could kick off World War III I also
okay I think it's fair to to to to state
that the problem we have here and the
the difficulty with this kind of
commentary is that you have dozens of
world leaders saying either World War II
is starting has already started or is
about to start then you have constant
tit fortat escalations and you and we
just don't know I mean we're in the
thick of it we can't tell we can't see
the forest we're inside of it this could
be the shotard around the world moment
but I don't think we would know until
well into any kind of actual War I do
believe however if Joe Biden does order
any kind of retaliation on on Iran
directly then it's F I think it's fair
to say at that point everything's going
to kick off Domino's one after another
so if there is action taken against Iran
and some capacity and then this ropes in
the other other countries in the bricks
Nations we may six months down the line
be like okay we're in World War I
history books will look back and say
that moment Joe Biden order retaliation
kicked things off I got to be honest I'd
actually think that October 7th may be
considered the start if World War III
kicks off you can ignore Ukraine people
will say well there were border
conflicts happening and there was
funding of war in Ukraine Afghanistan
collaps and things like that October 7th
was a massive escalation which results
in the houthi rebels shutting down you
know the the Red Sea basically shutting
down shipping which is now leading to a
dramatic escalation at some point
Venezuela can make a move on Guyana
China makes a move on Taiwan there you
go World War I yeah it's definitely
tense geopolitically I mean that that's
the funny thing about the Ukraine
conflict which is that for a while when
this was happening when Russia was
stationing troops along the border
everyone was like we're on the brink of
something we're on the brink of
something and they did shut down trade
and there all are all kinds of sanction
against Russia and ultimately we just
sort to learn to live with this conflict
I mean of course the US government is
paying billions of dollars to to uh
support Ukraine and the American
taxpayers are feeling the effect of that
at home but ultimately it doesn't seem
like that was enough to spark world War
3 this does seem like more of a a
tension building moment but maybe we'll
feel differently in six months you know
people like Lindsey Graham they've been
wanting Iran forever they want us inside
Iran they want to slide on in you know
occupy that space and just take it is
that why we have a small contingency in
Jordan are they bait for the mongers
well the other thing too is that
intercept is reporting we've got troops
in Yemen that the this is a White House
report saying we did and then in January
said actually no we don't uh we're we're
not sure there's any troops there we
we've we there's been a secret war in
Yemen going on for like a decade us has
been supplying weapons even under Trump
this is this is this has been ongoing
the question is when does it come to a
point where Russia China uh or any or
any bricks Nation for instance just
finally says yeah not it's full scale
it's
mobilization and would they right like
what who who's going to be the first to
admit that we're War I feel like no
country wants to be the one to say like
this this is it I think if we get if we
make it to the far future they're going
to have a hard time quantifying World
War III is separated from World War II
and World War I they're going to look at
this all it's like one long sustained
time of violence that's been going on
for uh decades I don't think so I mean
yeah sort of but World War I before
World War I there was the the the the
war starts because of the tensions then
World War II is kind of born out of
consequences from that I mean exactly we
but look we call World War I and World
War II separate despite the fact that
it's all basically the same conflict but
then I'm thinking like past that you
know we've been kind of doing these
weird scops on each other through you
know the internet and causing all this
turmoil whether the people claiming it's
rigged elections and whatnot I think
they might add those to the idea of what
the war has looked like because we've
entered this new digital space where the
war is on like the digital Battlefront
the the physical Battlefront we're
seeing it escalate now in the way we
think of war in the old school ways but
I think it's been going on kind of
psychologically well that makes me think
of like Tik Tok right I mean when Tik
Tok rolled out everyone realized what
kind of connection it had to the Chinese
government it was sort of this question
of oh what Warfare is being played even
though we are not actively at you know
at War there is there is always uh an
effort to have influence over another
Nation I don't think that ever went away
I I have proof that Tik Tock is war they
banned pop culture crisis I thought you
were to say because they crey but that's
also true so we have uh there's another
show at Tim cast.com pop culture C
crisis hosted by Brett desic and Mary
Morgan uh guests on Friday it's very
similar to timcast IRL and it structure
super chats commentary stories uh
podcast it's live uh every uh Monday
through Monday through Friday 3:00 to 5
and uh it's it's not a big political
show it's talking about like oh hey this
new movie came out this new video game
the point was to be able to have someone
some way that we could talk about pop
culture issues in this company when
we're mostly talking about news Tik Tok
banned them well was a reason of
community guidelines violations I I I
call Shenanigans I think the real issue
is controlling influence uh of their of
an adversary making sure that the work
we do can't expand timcast IRL got
banned from from Tik Tok a while ago and
then you know for no no no real reason
given they don't want us to be able to
have influence because the The Narrative
and the message that we share is good
for the United States and the narrative
and message that's on Tik Tok Dylan M
for instance is destroying the future
Generations I got banned from Tik Tok
right after I posted a video of me uh on
Infowars and I think Alex's voice just
like trips a wire on Tik Tok and it was
like immediately gone I was like I don't
even care I don't even like Tik Tok like
that it was fun sharing videos of me on
Infowars but it was immediate but Tik
Tok has such an influence on culture
right now I mean this is what happened
after the October 7th conflict broke out
this was one of the things that came up
that the conversation that was happening
between mainstream media or maybe even
on let's say Instagram was different
from the conversation that was happening
among younger gen Z on Tik Tok the the
the difference between the position on
being you know pro-israel versus being
pro Palestine became obvious on social
media more than anywhere else I mean it
was social media and college campuses
that really Led Led people to believe
that oh wait they have conflicting
opinions here we didn't expect it yeah
uh are you on Tik Tok no I banned myself
from me to the moment it it came into
existence fair play good but it is still
highly influential did you guys see that
uh Florida is proposing like Banning
Social Media for anyone under 16 what
with parental consent right there's a
couple states that are considering laws
like this so so a kid can go on if the
parents consent to it or what you have
to have parental consent if you're if
you're uh if you're a minor if you're
under 18 just like if a kid wants to go
to an adult bookstore he just needs
parental consent right yeah yeah and I
can't remember which state I'll look it
up in a second but one of them you know
you can't just say oh yeah my parents
said it was okay you have to they have
to like sign a document and send it into
the company
uh which I find interesting but again to
to your point you know the challenges
that this generation is facing in terms
of you
know trying to understand the challenges
that face their young generation are
very different than the parents who came
out of World War I or the parents who
came out of World War II and I think so
much of that has to do with the digital
age I mean we always see that during
times of threat it you know like after
911 theoretically this was a point where
a lot of people enrolled in enlisted in
the military and there was a sort of
spike in patriotism but that goes away
way people have their own questions
about the government's actions this
generation has seen so much tension and
conflict and in fact the fact that
they're always plugged in they're always
seeing clips of awful things all the
time could you inspire them to come
together I don't think so you're saying
that social media created the perfect
candidates for drone operators maybe or
just the perfect candidates to be
disengaged because they are ultimately
over stimulated by everything they see I
think it created a a generation of
broken brained people well that's what
the biggest danger is as my children
became teenagers and of course I could
watch on my iPhone what apps they were
downloading you know and my 14-year-old
son downloads Snapchat oh heck no you
know that comes off now you take it off
or I take the phone inantly snap's
creepy well it was it was creepy but you
know look the those guys on his baseball
team you know they're they're sharing
photos pictures and it would be
incredibly easy for them to make that
fatal mistake and they're branded as a
you know sexual predator for the rest of
their life yeah there been this is where
teenagers share photos of themselves and
it doesn't matter law doesn't say you or
anyone else like the law just says photo
of a minor done that's it and so they've
had like 14-year-old boys and girls have
to register as sex offenders because
they took pictures of themselves and
shared it but that's the law says or
there's been a couple cases where people
will connect with them effectively
catfish them they'll send like a nude
photo or whatever and then they'll
blackmail them and say like we have this
we're going to ruin your life there was
a I think a kid from Minnesota who
killed himself over this I mean this was
this is like a new danger that I think
parents are have never had to contend
with because they're basically inviting
strangers into their home constantly
through the cell phone thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net